- There's no excuse for
not talking to the world.
It just doesn't have to be
your thoughts
and words every time.
My friends, the
key to content success
is you've got to start
documenting instead of creating.
Let me tell you how.
Just start.
(upbeat music)
Hey guys, I know
I look like the Emperor
from Star Wars right now,
but I'm very high in
the air back from London
headed to New York City.
I decided to do a video.
So many of you are
stuck and can't start,
and I broke it down into the
what, how, and where, right?
WHW, right, like what
are you gonna talk about?
But the way all of
you need to do this
and how you
actually start is by doing.
You haven't done anything yet.
You know, this whole,
"Fake it 'til you make it"
brings no value to anybody.
You need to make something,
and that thing is a manifesto.
It's always been obvious to me,
it's always been
obvious what causes success,
what I needed to do, you know.
Every time I watch content on
the internet or on television,
I watched Oprah the other night,
Lizzie was watching,
I was working.
She was
interviewing George Lucas
and he was saying the same shit.
- We took it to all the studios,
every single one of
'em, and nobody wanted it.
- So what did you do?
- So I said, "Well,
I'm not gonna give up now."
- You're stuck.
You haven't started
'cause you're stuck.
I think the
fear of losing trumps
the excitement of
victory for so many people.
So here you go, what?
What are you gonna talk about,
what do you wanna be known for?
Look yourself in the
mirror and ask yourself,
"What do I want to do every
day for the rest of my life?"
Do that.
And see, what people
need to understand is,
the way we communicate
today is so different
and the platforms
have been redefined.
You wanna be in
health and fitness,
you wanna be in strategy,
you wanna be in social media,
you wanna be in sneakers,
you wanna be in coffee,
you wanna be in electronics,
you wanna be in fashion?
You collect Smurfs? Smurf it up.
You can make $70,000 a
year talking about the Smurfs.
Whether that's your mission
or where you're at right now,
your truth, manifesto.
Tell me what
you're thinking about it,
like, if somebody made
a video eight years ago
that I think
fashion should be high-low,
I think people
should wear expensive stuff
and inexpensive
stuff in one wardrobe,
they would've been like,
the queen or king of the vision
of the fashion industry
just by making a video.
- Predicting that
Facebook acquires Instagram.
- I was like, "Facebook's
gonna buy Instagram."
Four months later, it happens.
So I was on Piers Morgan.
This company's 550 days old.
How the hell is it
worth a billion dollars?
And my opening line is.
They stole it.
And then, I guess
last year this time, right,
Facebook bought
WhatsApp for $18 billion
and every article like the next
day after the news came out
is like, "Oh, wait a minute,
they fuckin' stole Instagram."
The how is, there's
only certain few ways
to communicate in the world.
Whether this is video form.
Something extreme,
like just get on a train
and go away for a week
or something different.
You have to break pattern.
Whether this is audio form.
Sitting here
listening to my music list
and I'm starting to
find a little clarity.
Audio being a podcast.
- You're an outspoken advocate
for both hustle
and self-awareness.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But if you had
to put them in order,
even if it's a 1A and 1B.
- [Gary] Self-awareness.
- Self-awareness is more
important than hustle?
- [Gary] It's not even close.
- Really?
- Yes, when you know who
you are, hustle's sexier.
Like, it would've been cooler
for like, the people listening
for me to say
hustle 'cause it's cooler.
Right, heck, you don't
even need to do a podcast.
Put the recorder on your phone
and just speak your truth.
As I sit here right
now writing this article,
or at least memoing it
'cause that's how I do it.
Get in front of a
camera, selfie-style.
You know, I'm old now, kids,
so at 40, I've observed a lot,
and I could tell
you that optimism
and positivity
is a huge variable.
Good morning, Instagram.
It's me, Gary.
Instead of a motivational
quote or some sort of clip,
I just wanted to
go camera to face,
just tell you how much
I appreciate all of you guys.
Your attention
means the world to me.
Set it up on a
tripod or have a DRock,
if it's your
nephew, your sister.
Nate, give me this,
give me this real quick.
Nathan, the intern is here.
Some of you guys
might remember him.
Or you write it, but the way
all of you need to do this
and how you
actually start is by doing.
I create an
obnoxious amount of content
because of the
strategy of how we do it.
Don't do anything,
just keep watching.
Keep watching my stuff.
Keep being
entertained by my energy.
Keep being inspired, don't do.
Don't fuckin' have dinner
at 7:00 and drink two beers.
Like, when your
strategy is right, you win,
and so we have figured
out that pillar content
creates content
underneath it at scale.
Hey everybody, welcome to
the first #AskGaryVee.
I think it's the first one,
but I actually do think
I tried to do this once before.
I feel like I've got
the team now in place
to actually do this more often.
It's macro patience.
Macro patience.
Deploy patience.
You've gotta deploy patience.
You've gotta love the process.
What's the ROI of social media?
So I look at her and go,
"What's the ROI of your mother?"
There are so many people in here
that shouldn't
be producing video
because that is not the
best way they communicate.
Only a decade ago,
if I was speaking here,
all I would be
talking about is blogging,
yet, there are
people in this room
that are caught up by
picture and video communication
and they are tremendous writers
and they don't realize that
blogging or posting on Medium
or even my favorite
little hack right now,
if you're a good writer and
you wanna build up a profile
for your
business or for yourself,
I actually highly
recommend you start blogging
inside of
Facebook and Instagram.
I literally mean
writing seven, 15, 25 sentences,
three, four, five
paragraphs of written content
within your feeds that people
will absolutely consume.
So that's number one and
two, the what and how, right,
like how are you gonna do it,
and then where, distribution.
That's what you
need to figure out next
and it's the hardest
part for a lot of you.
The hardest part is to start,
and a lot of things are hard.
Hard to start, hard to
know what format to do it in,
audio, written, video,
and then number three,
how do you get people to see it?
It all goes down in the DM.
The key is providing
other people more value.
I just don't
see people doing it.
It blows me away,
and it is absolutely,
I want the full,
and it as absolutely
going down on Instagram DM.
Influencers or you pay for it.
Either you pay in Facebook ads,
Instagram ads,
sponsorship deals.
YouTube pre-rolls against
people of those interests,
fashion, you know, food,
wine, sneakers, technology,
or, or you reach out to
people that have audiences.
Search hashtags, click them,
look at the account,
then see how you
can bring them value.
DM them, go in soft,
bring value.
Rinse and repeat, two,
three, four, 5,000 times,
so the thing you Manny should
do is go Upper East Side.
Looking good, this guy,
look like a good picture.
Hey G.
Instagram influencers
right now today for doers
is probably only
behind Facebook ads,
the single best
arbitrage in marketing.
And then you try
and then you learn.
When you're a pioneer,
you have to taste it.
There's no report.
There's no white paper.
There's no
modeling mixed metrics
that are gonna teach
you how that's gonna work.
When you're the first explorer,
you have to taste the berries,
and hopefully
they're not poisonous.
We're living
through this incredible era
of massive opportunity, yet
everybody's talking and reading,
and nobody's fucking doing.
Start fucking executing.
So, what does that mean?
That means you should write a
Medium blog post every week.
Content, podcast,
video, written,
quotes, pictures,
and then tactics.
What scares me quite a
bit is that most of you,
when you see these logos,
you think of a piece
of content that you make
and you think of
those five channels and more
as places where
you distribute it.
Twitter and Facebook are tools.
Twitter and Facebook
are markers and crayons.
They're a fax machine.
These are not just
distribution channels.
These are channels where you
have to natively story tell.
Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, and Instagram
are ABC, NBC, and CBS,
and what I've figured
out for the last decade
is how to make MASH
and the Andy Griffith Show
and ER and Seinfeld.
- And my question is, how
I hustle and stop being a pussy?
Like, I wanna be where you are.
- [Gary] What's blocking you?
- I don't know.
- [Gary] Other people's POV?
- Yes.
- [Gary] That's the one, man.
It's good to see
classic and in style.
I wouldn't guess
Santa Rita Hills.
Yes, that's a dig,
little sniffy sniff.
Please, take a step
back and think about
how awesome it actually is.
It is imperative that not only
do you start thinking about
your content strategy on these
platforms for your business.
Facebook targeting.
I mean like, I mean that's it.
Like, you can literally
put your business address,
run a radius around it,
or everybody in
the 07081 zip code
or the 08802, Asbury
Jersey in the house, zip code,
and everybody will see it in
that zip code in that feed.
It's a piece of cake.
So if you talk about coffee,
Google the word coffee
and the word blog or
coffee and media company
and literally email
every editor and writer
of every coffee
blog on the internet.
The way you're
gonna make money online,
and by the way,
anywhere, is by grabbing it.
So if I were you,
I would do this.
I would go to Google,
I would type in beer.
So I would click
this one, PubGlasses.com.
I'd go to this site,
I'd see what they have.
I would find the
phone number of this place.
Here's a phone number.
I pick it up.
Hello, who
would I speak to about
you guys possibly
advertising on my beer blog?
- [Dean] That's me,
the owner, Dean.
- Then, search
the hashtag coffee
and go to every
coffee influencer
and coffee barista and
coffee media site on Instagram
and DM them and ask
them to give awareness
to this manifesto
you just wrote,
and one out of 147 will,
but that's better than zero.
Undervaluing just that one view,
it needs to be the right view,
but it's one view,
is a humongous mistake.
That's it, that's
how you do it, the what.
That I'm willing to sit here
right now and make this video,
hoping that one
fucker, one fucker,
says, "Oh shit, yeah,"
like, "Fuck it."
The where.
That's written word.
You look at the Mediums,
LinkedIn, the WordPresses.
You start a blog, right, or
you do it on your Facebook
or you do it on your Instagram.
The how.
There's only really three core
ways in the current internet
to really
communicate to the world.
The written word, or
video, what I'm doing right now.
YouTube, Facebook video,
Instagram, one minute versions.
Video is the other
way we communicate,
and number three,
audio, the boom of podcasts.
These are things that matter.
What the fuck do
you wanna talk about?
How are you gonna communicate
it, written, audio, or video,
and how do you give
people to actually see it?
This is where we showed you
how to go into the DM, right,
or you've gotta figure
out how to use some money
and use Facebook ads
and target the people
that you're trying to
reach, or grinding hustle,
just literally
emailing 700 to 1,500
different blogs or
media sites and saying,
"Do you wanna
distribute my content?"
Somebody has a 14,000
person email newsletter
about coffee news.
Find that person and ask them.
You just gotta ask,
and be smart.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Ask them what
you can do for them
because you want
everybody to read this.
Post it on Medium
and hit up the editors
of Medium who curate content.
Post a link on it
and to Reddit, right?
Hit up the 4,700
coffee influencers on YouTube
and send them a message and
ask them if they wanna read it
on their YouTube
channel that has 147 views.
147 views is better than zero.
The fuckin' work,
that's how you start.
(upbeat music)